okay
now this this is something that's like
pretty intense to me
is that the average nba career
lasts 4.5 years four and a half years
and the uh and
eighty percent i think this is right
eighty percent of all
nba players are completely dead broke
and in debt within five years of the end
of their nba career
and i mean dude that's just plain
upsetting
and and what i think is so impressive
about you is that you've really made
efforts
to help people who are new in the nba to
plan out their
financial future yeah i try to talk to
them and let them know because
you know like like a lot of times for
example i had a contract that was
worth 100 mil but in real life it's not
worth 100 it was 50
mil right i remember when i first got to
l.a
i forgot who fico was and when i first
got to la i got a check for 20 million
so i go in the rolls-royce store i got
on sweatpants
and i look at the guy and i was like oh
hey let me how much does this cost
250. and in my mind i don't want to
spend 250 for a car so a guy says to me
can you afford it sonny
oh i bought three cars right there which
is a million dollars which
is a waste of money then i'm riding
through beverly hills i see a house
beautiful house in the mountains
perfect seven million i buy the house
cash so
it's been eight million probably like in
two days so then my guy calls me and
said you know you spent your whole check
and in my mind i was like no i'm getting
20 issues he's like no
in california 20 only comes out to 10.5
you just spent eight million in two days
you only got two million left so after
that i really had to slow down because
like a lot of times we get these big
numbers
and we focus on the big numbers we're
gonna focus on the reality like
uh tax family employees
flossing spending and wasting so
even though it says like a lot of guys
are broke it's really easy to do
you know you can always get people to
always say oh what if i get a million
i'm going to keep it
no because one domain is not a million
it's 500 000.
you still got to live your life and you
just got to be smart with it so some
guys are smart
some guys aren't for sure and and when
you say uh
100 million hey i don't want to talk to
you i want to talk to the other guy
who's just sitting there like yeah
you're right yeah
i forgot i didn't introduce my co-host
scott randall
he's six for six for not introducing me
so it's okay
what's up dude yeah i was really
interested in that and and so so when
money comes in
the first thing you do is you take 50
out put it in a tax account
the other 20 25 are you investing that
or what are you doing with that well
when i first came out i had to i had to
take care of the
the obvious first so my first couple
years i didn't save at all because i
wanted to make sure my mom
and dad and brother and sister were
financially secure
now when you get extra money you invest
you know a lot of people always say
invest invest but you have to invest in
the right things
so of course i put a lot of money like
you said and uh
you know annuities i put a lot of money
and you know blue chip companies
companies that you know apple
ge stuff like that and then you know you
try to invest in the right business
but you have to be business-minded like
for example you can't
be an nba player and run a restaurant so
which means you have to you have to do a
jv with a restaurant tour
like for example like if i'm gonna do a
show that's dealing with crazy people
i'm just gonna do a deal with stevie
won't say stevo where's the money here's
the concept
let's get it done rather than me out
there sticking needles in my balls and
stapling
yeah you gotta delegate thank you so
much for watching this clip
and guess what i have the number 30
ranked hot sauce on all of amazon
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping
me because right now we're ranked number
30 on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude